there is encouraging news in the race to
develop a corona virus vaccine the first
vaccine tested in this country is set to
begin its final phase of testing later
this month
moderna published its phase 1 results in
a peer-reviewed journal all 45
volunteers who receive this vaccine
produced an immune response and showed
no serious safety concerns the vaccine
was developed with the National
Institutes of Health our dr. David agus
joins us now to discuss that story David
good morning to you it sure sounds
promising is it yeah this is the first
u.s. trial it is a phase one it is very
small 45 you know by comparison the
oxford vaccine is in 14 thousand
patients so very different than the 45
here but what they showed in the New
England Journal of Medicine is very good
antibody responses and some t-cell
responses so they're mimicking what
happens when you have the virus with a
little bit stronger antibody responses
so it's about as good as we could hope
for from a phase 1 clinical trial and
now we go to the pivotal study mm-hm so
what are we talk about that what do we
know about the safety and what do we
know about the side effects of this drug
you always have to ask about those
things so what we know is that it was
remarkably well tolerated about half of
the patients had fever chills sore arm
what you expect from a vaccine nobody
had a serious adverse event so well
tolerated there were three doses the
middle dose seemed to have an optimal
immune response and when you went to my
higher dose more side effects without
more of an immune response there going
forward with the middle dose in the
phase 3 clinical trial so phase 3 you
talked about that as the pivotal phase
what happens in that trial so in the
phase 3 trial we give half the
volunteers placebo and half the
volunteers vaccine and then we say go
into the world and you know do your
normal behavior and we'll see if this
protects people from the virus
so what's incumbent there is that it has
to go into areas that we predict will
have high numbers of cases of the virus
if we inject people in part of the
country where the virus goes away the
result isn't gonna yield information the
way this phase 3 is designed with 30,000
patients the hope is we receive data by
Thanksgiving and again that presupposes
that we can predict where they're going
to be outbreaks in the country because
that's where we'll do most of the
vaccinations yeah a lot of people
thinking about Thanksgiving or
rethinking Thanksgiving plans when
you're here the other day we talked
about the antibody levels in patients
declining after sometime after they
after they recover how will this affect
the vaccine development it's the key
question is that everybody is focused on
antibody levels data has come out in two
separate studies showing that after two
or three months people who got the virus
the vaccine anybody levels went down and
that was worrisome what's critical here
is T cells T cells are the other part of
the immune system that are very potent
in fighting the virus and have memory
the moderna vaccine showed that it
actually did turn on T cells how much
and how long is the critical question we
don't know because we only have the
short-term data from this phase one
study and so what we're hoping and
praying for is that it will be
long-acting and there will be long-term
immunity we know anybody's on everything
right if they go away in two or three
months we haven't yet seen secondary
infections that is somebody getting the
virus twice in this country so clearly
t-cells are a big part so David what
still could go wrong here we're so
optimistic once of actually what still
could go wrong
so you mean what keeps me up at night
what keeps me up at night if you don't
get any separate things what is we don't
yet have a test for immunities when we
give a vaccine I want to know how long
Gail is protected and when she's going
to need a booster and if I don't have a
test for that immunity I'm not sure when
I'm going to give it to her second is is
that while we have these good immune
responses seen in the phase one are they
enough to block the virus from causing
its problem the FDA has set a bar that
unless you reduce symptoms by 50%
they're not going to approve the vaccine
so we have a bar which i think is
fantastic that they set that we have to
get there
the third and I think really critical is
that we don't politicize this vaccine if
the data on some of the vaccines and
they will be out on the oxford vaccine
early come out and this September
beginning of October if I am afraid will
be politicized and people will be afraid
to get the vaccine because they think
it's politics not science science has to
win here yeah yes who would have thought
masks would become a political hot
potato but say you get kovat let's
forget about the vaccine for a second
say you get kovat in your you've
recovered can you get reinfected again
at some point the answer will be yes in
the United States now we don't have a
documented case of somebody reinfected
with koban 19 at some point immunity
will run out and we will see significant
numbers of people with secondary
infections and sometimes they can be
more serious than the first which is
what has us worried so we're waiting
we're on guard and we're looking but we
have yet to see that wave if you will in
the United States alright David agus
thank you very much always good to see
you